et maintenant
je
bref yvan attal
sa vie mon histoire commence à martigues
bien bien à la maison ça va tout va bien
je crois - charlotte jour actrice ouais
toujours l'actrice d' analyse ça va ça
fait pas un peu marque de glaces
américaine ben non pas penser à ça
maintenant je sais ça fait classe
américaine et jane belle-mère ça va ça
va bien ça fait longtemps que je n'ai
pas vu et louvre belle soeur 120
elle va bien elle tourne avec les génies
de doyen soit un film gore je crois bien
avec cloud vous allez tourner ma belle
soeur est une actrice
moi j'aimerais bien tourné avec lou a
beaucoup arrêts non c'est vrai bon alors
on pas parler de sexe tout de suite ils
vendent pas parler d'argent n'ont pas
d'argent
sans lui où il vend le remake de ma
femme est une actrice aux états unis ils
sont en train de céans production ils
sont en train de l'écrire et un
scénariste dessus il y avait chez eux
peiné robin wright qui étaient
intéressés par le remake pour jouer ne
pas pas fashion pas ne voulais pas le
mettre en scène mais jouer dedans donc
on attend sais pas ce qui va se passer
pour l'instant il adapte le scénario
quand je lis le film s'est lancé sur ce
média jeter sur les américains fera
remake
ils ont pas d idée comme ça qu'ils se
disent alors à la fin juin quand on vous
êtes venus pour la dernière fois yvan
attal c'était là la sortie en vhs et dvd
justement de ma femme est une actrice et
vous étiez sur le point de passer l'été
à tourner un film avec isabelle adjani
et et virginie ledoyen et vous m'aviez
dit d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas le
bon rôle parce que celui qui sait taper
toutes les deux en chine et un autre
acteur on sait qui c'est maintenant
effectivement alors ce film donc sort
mercredi il s'appelle bon voyage c'est
le nouveau film de jean paul rappeneau
râpeux il a fait sept films en 35 ans
non quand il fait un film devance au
mieux qu on va le voir regarde et des
bonbons oui et et bon voyage il l'a
écrit avec patrick modiano
il ya isabelle adjani gérard depardieu
virginie ledoyen grégori derangère celui
qui choque plus qu yvan peter coyote et
vous ça se passe en 1940 la france
s'écroule devant l'avancée allemande
le tout paris politique bourgeois monde
interlope artistique qui de paris et se
retrouve à bordeaux à l'hôtel splendid
voilà comment suite à l'hôtel du parc à
vichy alors tout le monde est là dans le
même restaurant il ya des temps qui
croissent de bol c'est une espèce de
chaudron une situation tragique comique
parce qu'évidemment les événements très
graves
nous devons y a plein d'histoires qui se
mélange à ça alors arnaud lui il avait
huit ans donc il a il a bien connu il a
bien connu l'époque et il cherchait
quelque chose à faire autour de ça et un
jour il apprend qu'à ce moment là
effectivement les prisons étaient vides
et ouverte
quand les allemands sont arrivés grégori
derangère et vous vous êtes deux
prisonniers qui vous évader ensemble lui
c'est un écrivain il est là on va voir
pourquoi vous vous êtes un voleur lui il
est accusé à tort d'un crime commis par
isabelle adjani depardieu et emilie
sera moureu d'elle et virginie ledoyen
est assistante d'un savant et tous
accourent à 100 kilomètres à l'heure
c'est 14 cents plants dans ce film ça
virevolte complètement dans son plan 14
ans bah oui non j'ai vu d'abord des
lancements oui j'ai vu la bande annonce
faisait la revoir